tout le monde joue quand vous prenez un
risque vous jouez et si vous jouez je
suis votre homme bienvenue à bord
nous sommes le plus grand modèle
économique de la planète cinquante mille
joueurs par jour un million neuf cent
mille dollars la journée alors qu'est ce
que t'en dis
qu'est ce que vous croyez
les bouteilles d'eau pour un chacun
apprécie sa chance plus ou moins
l'eau peuple mais rêvent que d'une chose
coince et rien qui il avait signé comme
le visage de la culture ces blogs qui
t'envoient il cherche à te faire porter
le chapeau tu t'es fait attraper par le
fbi tu comptes faire quoi maintenant
la vie est ainsi faite tu peux plus
rentrer maintenant que la fête bat son
plein à merde
ton post confie la mission d'aller te
faire démonter tu y vas et tu remplis
qu'en disant est ce que vous voulez que
ça va prendre encore eu de
justin timberlake gemma arterton et ben
affleck je vais trouver le moyen de nous
sortir de la bonne chance les gars le 25
septembre au cinéma
m